one of America's Best Known home goods
stores is dead Bed Bath and Beyond
emptying shelves as it could be etching
closer to bankruptcy this is a classic
tale of a failed brick and mortar
retailer because of the issues with
adapting to the modern consumer
signs are already out in the stores
Everything Must Go Bed Bath and Beyond
was unique because it was the first meme
stock to go bankrupt and unless a new
buyer emerges it all comes to an end
June 30th
[Music]
Bed Bath and Beyond got famous for these
blue and white coupons and it was almost
like the Willy Wonka golden ticket and
since it's 20 off Mama gets something
for herself
people would really rely on those
discounts for kind of these life
Milestones let me guess you're shopping
for college yeah
Bed Bath and Beyond stores are in all 50
states DC Puerto Rico and Canada and
it's Bye Bye Baby brand which is
considered one of its Crown Jewel assets
operates in 35 states to understand the
company's downfall we need to go back to
its beginnings
so Bed Bath and Beyond is a 50 year old
retailer you could get furniture you
could get bedding you could get kitchen
supplies and they had the types of name
brands that consumers really wanted
you'll be an amazing Chef in no time
bam one of the reasons that Bed Bath and
Beyond started to struggle was that they
were losing relevance in the e-commerce
area what is this
oh this is called offline shopping it's
like online shopping but in real life
and so what they did was they hired Mark
Tritton who was a former executive at
Target really excited to bring this new
store to New York it also represents the
DNA of our remodels across the country
over the next three years I declared to
step up and Beyond store officially open
oh
unfortunately Mark tritton's tenure
began right as the pandemic started what
we're finding is that the pandemic has
really accelerated the customer's
relationship with digital at the same
time companies like Amazon were offering
cheap Goods delivered to your doorstep
whereas Bed Bath and Beyond was behind
on an e-commerce strategy and so they
couldn't capture those consumers that
were then locked down at home
as Bed Bath and Beyond started to come
into financial trouble in 2022 this
company was losing its Partners light
KitchenAid
the company was laying off workers
cutting and spending and closing down
stores but at that point it was really
too late just because it had such a
large debt load I needed to pay back
creditors and such a short time frame
and that was really the beginning of the
end for this brand
foreign
stocks really came on to this scene both
on Wall Street and Main Street back in
early 2021 a lot of that strength was
because individual investors flocking to
things like stock twits Discord YouTube
and Reddit were encouraging others to
buy shares and it really took on a
completely different flavor in March and
April 2022 when Ryan Cohen the founder
of Chewie and chairman of the board at
GameStop disclosed a stake in Bed Bath
and Beyond we saw investors really
rushing into it touting Cohen's position
and that really further fueled the gains
the shares are up close to 200 percent
this month you know this is uh GameStop
from a couple years ago and it's
happening again just a few months after
that filing Cohen sold the shares and
that really left investors especially
retail investors kind of whether it was
time to throw in the towel and move on
to the next investment I just wonder how
much money was lost by people doing the
meme thing with Bed Bath and Beyond
[Music]
as Bed Bath and Beyond was kind of at
the brink of bankruptcy it decided to
make this effort to raise Equity the
company did a few unconventional
offerings one was selling shares at a
discount to hedge funds that could then
quickly sell the shares into the open
market and profit that kept the lights
on for a few months and then when that
hit a wall the company struck another
agreement or they sold shares into the
open market further diluting individual
investors who had been holding on for
dear life or hodl as they say and when
you look at the profits the company was
taking from those share sales they very
quickly turned it around and gave it to
creditors like JP Morgan
all told short sellers made just over a
billion dollars and Retail investors who
drove the shares over the last two years
are left holding a basically emptied bag
losing probably hundreds of millions of
dollars
other retailers are already profiting
off Bed Bath and Beyond's demise Big
Lots and The Container Store are
accepting those famous 20 off bed bath
coupons at their own locations the
bankruptcy will likely reward other big
box stores as well
Bed Bath and Beyond has a massive
footprint in the U.S at the time of the
bankruptcy the company had 14 000
employees in the U.S and Puerto Rico
that being said many of the employees
especially in the retail stores
themselves don't know how much longer
they'll have their jobs or what their
longer term fate is once the stores are
officially closed
foreign